this gent joining in right now is going
to be calling clemson and notre dame
on abc uh what what time is that going
to be mike del tufo
four p.m eastern thank you i turned i
turned to the man from new jersey
who never went to notre dame but claims
them as his own team 43 years
i always turn to you since you're so
locked in um he's calling this game on
abc he's also got a dynamite podcast
that i was on
that he uh co-produces with his wife
jennifer chris fowler here on the show
how are you chris
outstanding rich happy holidays how are
you i'm great chris
um i don't know if you watched the first
hour of this show
here on on peacock but uh there was a
debut
uh in the first hour of the program as i
talked about the blowouts that you've
been calling that we assume will not
happen this weekend
stanley the cat made a peacock uh debut
in hour number one staring you down i've
alerted jennifer i appreciate that that
stanley
stanley's uh you may have a brand maybe
building a brand around him
indeed yes you're staring is she staring
you down uh after calling it
well the story is look i mean i i live
we live in miami beach a lot of the time
so that was a home game yes the latest
beat down the long season of them
we come home we're having dinner he does
something he's never done before he
jumps on the chair at the head of the
dining room table and puts his face on
top of the table and as
you showed the picture a forlorn look
but also an empathetic book like i
cannot believe
you had to call another blowout when i
know you had high expectations
for this game is there anything i can do
yes it's been rough
he was he was offering support and your
family are animal lovers so you
understand the importance of that
emotional support at a time of need and
you guys kind of provide it for me
well the in the question that was
provided in the copy uh on this
photograph will you ever call a close
game again
i think i think we know the answer to it
and i think you're about to chris let's
put it that way oh not so fast my friend
i hope we thought last week was going to
be great
last week was a three point carolina was
an underdog
went up by 36. now notre dame yes and i
just got off the phone with tell you a
guy there your irish fan that i i just
got off the phone with the in book and
brian kelly and those guys and they they
feel the chip too because vegas has made
them a ten and a half point underdog in
round two so
both teams kind of arrive with the chip
yes we have high expectations but
i am so i am so brutalized by the the
scores rich that i
no longer go in optimistic i go in
neutral expecting nothing and i'd be
pleasantly surprised if you get a
classic well it looks like again these
are evenly matched teams based on what
we saw
earlier this year and i know that trevor
lawrence did not play in that game
in south bend and he will play in this
one how do you see that
playing out going in have you spoken to
trevor lawrence as well yet
i have a notre dame student's got in his
face he's pretty easy to spot you know
just six blonde hair no helmet after the
game and they
they bum rushed the field in the mosh
pit afterwards
some of them found trevor and james
skalsky
who's not a cat you want to get in his
face of the middle linebacker crimson
who also missed that first game because
of an injury
not cove but he's due back and those
guys said a little extra fuel
not that you need it but little extra
fuel because notre dame students let
them know
all about what had just happened and you
know trevor's kind of a
he's a quiet competitor he doesn't
grandstand his his emotions but he
he feels them i i think uh yeah that
doesn't mean you're gonna win the game
it's just more fuel
well i mean and we had dabo on the show
two weeks ago
um and i asked him point blank you know
do you think
because of the stakes that this game
clearly has that the loser of this game
might be on the outside looking in
looking at a team
that has played half of the number of
games that either one of these have
played
uh getting in and they're out um asking
that of dabo
essentially is is ohio state the ohio
state
can you throw him a giant
he sure did he spit it out and swallowed
the bones too
that you know and and i asked brian
kelly as the same question when i
had him on two days before and these
guys are like we've gone through a whole
season
uh in covid and these kids have played
it all they they've
spilled their hearts out and that nobody
that's played half a schedule
as we have deserves to be in essentially
is what i'm i'm i'm wrapping it up
what do you think of this subject going
into this game because i'm sure you and
i
will be talking about it i think they're
i think their feelings are
are genuine i do think that part of it
also nobody really wants to see ohio
state
in there if you have a choice to have
another team you might might choose that
because
we know that they're good enough to win
it if they get in it but should they be
that that's a very fair question i i i
would tend to
be in line with dabo and brian kelly's
opinion and yeah i know how challenging
it's been week to week
um i know with the mental wear and tear
beyond the physical stuff these teams
have gone through when you played double
the schedule basically
you had double the duress and then ohio
state to arrive
you know not that they haven't had
stress when they miss games don't get me
wrong it's stressful to sit games out
and they're going through
practice and all that but still when you
have to lay it out there on the field
and this is game six for them and i
think you know the rumors that are
swirling by the way that they are going
to face northwestern
likely down um a top-line receiver or
two we don't know for sure they put that
off until tomorrow but there are more
coveted issues in the ohio state program
and if they follow the protocol
that set out by the big ten and the cfp
requires you to go back to your
conference protocol
they would miss the playoffs because the
playoff is right up close to these end
of the games
and so um that that's in play too that
that's sort of tomorrow's news but it's
already been leaking out for the last
24 to 36 hours maybe it's crystal lobby
maybe it's scary wilson nobody's saying
for sure i don't know for sure
but those are the names those are
important names to have an ohio state's
team but
but no i think that the committee's
already kind of weighed in on that
though haven't they rich and that's why
kelly and dabo are upset about it
because they're already in the top four
having played
five games and it's not like they face
murderers row let's be honest okay
indiana was a seven point win and it's
proven to be
a quality team but that's pretty much it
in terms of the teams that they've
handled
on their schedule uh something to brag
about and that's that's a factor too if
you played five
really strong teams that's different
than the schedule they played so
it's a vowel issue it's not personal
ohio state fans always think it's
personal
they have a very vocal energized fan
base if you didn't know
so they're going to act like it's a
conspiracy we're being singled out i
mean
it's not that it's just whatever team
was in their position i think you could
feel the same way about it regardless of
who it is and did brian kelly bring up
to you what he said on a zoom earlier
today about
maybe if they wind up in the rose bowl
where covert protocols are keeping
fans from the stands that they wouldn't
play at a site that doesn't allow
families in there he was pretty hot
about it i'm wondering if
did he bring that up he was he was
emotional on our call i could feel it
catching in his voice when he was
talking about the idea
of players parents not being able to see
their sons play
after all that families have been
through this season right
it's not being a typical year in that
way i think he felt more strongly about
it
he did not proclaim that they would be
reluctant to play in a game where the
parents couldn't attend i
i don't know what that's about i i
seriously doubt if
notre dame is seated two or three and
heads to pasadena and i'm presuming
alabama's going to win by the way if
alabama wins they're they're a
lead pipe lock to be in new orleans as
the top seed
and and the 2-3 game would be in
pasadena
and you know you don't want to be the
four seed
in theory so you like to be two or three
which would put them
i don't know if it'd be clemson notre
dame around three or what but the 2-3
game is very likely to be there
it's certain to be there if alabama wins
but yeah i mean
do you think there's any chance you're
out there i'm not the chance that the
results get
they make an exception i don't have any
problem with people
lobbying and trying to leverage to get
regulations
changed i just know that in california
relaxing regulations
does not seem likely at this point given
what else is going on up there but i
don't know the climate that much
i'll be very honest with you chris that
there there was a video that went viral
uh here in california and across the
country of
a bar owner who uh in state in here in
los angeles
was told that she could not have any
outdoor seating that she spent
thousands upon thousands of dollars
putting together and across the street
there was an outdoor tent for seating
for craft services
for a movie or a tv show that was being
shot or a commercial
and there's a lot of sensitivities about
out here
about making exceptions for businesses
that uh that that are not made for
regular everyday businesses it's very
it's really raw out here man there's no
other way to put it and i
i don't know the way through it the
49ers as you know or a home team in
arizona because of what's going up in
santa clara
it's it's you know and it's it's just
like every other
part of our life where covet is putting
a thumb
of pressure on every pressure point and
and we're all feeling it and that's one
of the reasons why i was wondering
why didn't the college committee decide
and i understand i i guess i
dabo swinney's like when i brought this
up with him he's like we didn't want to
extend the season another day
but you know why not have eight teams
you know what i'm saying like we could
avoid all this and get coastal carolina
involved and
and do this you just play just a couple
extra games like
that did you ever hear anything about
that to try and change things around in
the same way that baseball did for its
expanding playoffs and so on and so
forth did you hear anything like that
this year chris no because there's no
central control of the sport rich had
there been i think that makes a lot of
sense you could have done it from the
start
the conferences would have had to start
closer together but you're right it
would have been a perfect year for an 18
playoff people have been clamoring for
it anyway i think
i think you're you're seeing some other
things unrelated to covid
in the sport that are kind of pushing us
toward um
playoff expansion for very legitimate
reasons but because
every conference although they claim to
be working and communicating together
before this
really they're out there for their own
interests and that's the way it's always
been
so the fact that they started a
staggered time kind of ruled out
an expanded playoff but it's too bad i
agree this would have been a good year
for it
so um which game are you calling of
college football
uh cemu are you going to be out here for
the rose bowl is that the plan that for
you right likely
that that's been the pattern yeah i mean
we when when the rose bowl is in play
we've done it
that's the thing too is that it's not as
simple as just you know
the cfp saying hey forget the rose bowl
moving the game to dallas which has been
the source of speculation or anywhere
else
because of the special relationship with
that game and it is a standalone event
it is the granddaddy
it does have a special place in the
history of the sport the rotation comes
around
every three years the rose bowl hosts
the semi-final game
in concert with the game in the
superdome it's not as simple
to say hey move it this year they get it
back next year i mean
i mean anything is possible you've seen
rules changed and altered
right to achieve the desired outcome
constantly
so it's not impossible it's just not
simple and i think that the
the relationship's a little uneasy the
cfp
and the rose bowl i mean they're both
you know
institutions now right it's been around
a lot longer than the other and i just
don't think it's as simple as any other
game i think it'd be much easier to move
it
um but listen i'll show up wherever they
send us
sure no no and and i i think what people
have to understand too
what you described is very important
that i don't think brian kelly or devil
understand
it's not just it's a massive place put a
few hundred people in there i understand
that makes sense
i think the risk would be very very low
but people spaced out
but you have to bring in security and
concessions you have to put people
who would normally and i have to work
that game even if you have any fans in
there as you know
it it's it's not as simple as opening
the gates go find a seat right you enjoy
your your son's name it's not it's not
that easy
definitely not however it's not it's not
like it's not doable
also i just i think you're right the
climate out there is so
so fraught and so unique right now chris
fowler here on the rich eisen show uh
let's turn to your pod before we send
you back into your day getting ready for
this
this great game who you got uh it's
called fowler who you got
and you've got jeanette lee and jay
billis
this week you've got barkley next i did
it uh
to uh i think i was in the inaugural
episode
uh you were the inaugural jumbo multiple
double album episode yes you're very
gracious told some great stories
it's fun we had some fun and that's sort
of the theme it's not really sports
although there are sports people all
over it but
some that you named but it's just as you
do this every day you talk to
interesting people about different
topics
you learn a lot inspiring is an overused
word we have dan patrick on though
talking about
um you know his his serious prolonged
battle with depression and he man
he opened his heart and he bled and he
was he it was important to hear him say
that and we gotten a lot of tremendous
feedback
harry goldman a comedian same thing
mental health has been a focus of the
pod and will continue to be because it
just helps people and we need it now
more than ever
for dan that the podcast format is you
know kind of lends
itself to just kind of a relaxed
in-depth conversation about stuff that
you wouldn't normally get to
and that's what's been fun i mean
charles is just making makes people
laugh that's a christmas gift
you know i love it in one finale
i mean it's about supposed to be about
golf stories because he loves golf
that's his
biggest passion in life i think
including basketball
but he talks about everything he talks
about football bo jackson announcing
social media gambling i mean we hit on
everything that's the way charles
operates so
that'll be fun and it's where all
podcasts are acquired and uh and
jennifer's uh producing it correct
with you right she's co-executive
producing it it's been a fun
collaboration she has a lot of input
um we edit it together
how does that work how does that work
chris how's that process
what what what to leave and what to cut
out
right they're healthy discussions but
they're they're loving
these questions it's good this has been
fun i mean like charles needed no
editing so it was easy
by the way there's nothing that requires
to hit the cutting room floor charles
barkley you got to put every last ounce
in there as well
and then uh stanley does stanley have a
say and what gets into the uh to the pod
or not to stan or just stand like he's
starting
to he's trying to flex a little bit i
think he's he's um if he yawns or nods
off i guess that's feedback because it's
having to say but when when a creature
sleeps 20 hours a day how much
i mean if he goes to sleep just because
he might mean he
is because he's a cat it might not mean
it's because the topic is boring so
understood
yeah can't take it personally can't take
it personally but uh but
and i just hope you did not properly
read into him staring at you
saying that another blowout is coming
because i think clemson and notre dame
is going to be great and um
one last thing chris just a moment for
for for me
uh to use a uh i guess a kilborn uh turn
here
how is trevor um i'm speaking as uh you
know
a jet fan and you know uh your wife is
from the long island area so you must uh
know through her
a bunch of jet fans how is trevor doing
um
is he is he ready to you know
come north i haven't uh i haven't
brought up the the jets
topic with him um we may with a few
other conversations around if he's a
heisman finalist i think
sure i mean i think his focus is where
it needs to be but i also think he is so
ready man he
is he's physically and mentally ready
he's as ready as you can be
i think i told you i saw him in the
spring before his freshman season
because you see you hear about these
guys and you want to see in person and
you go
ah okay i get it
the arm but just the presence the
charisma he's so
mentally advanced um i think you know
it's a test of all that though when you
go to organization
as well i'll i'll choose my words
carefully as struggling as the jets are
it's okay i mean it's okay chris when he
ran away when he
think you really you really wouldn't
wish on a player you've enjoyed covering
in college all the time because the best
players go to the worst teams
you always feel like oh joe burrow ah
street calls like the black hole of the
nfl but
you know but then again you know look
what baker's not in cleveland
exactly what lamar's done is successful
i see all these heisman guys go ahead
and go in there and
you can turn it man it's beautiful so
sure now
turning it is not easy no i i i know
that but when he
when he ran away from the ohio state
defense in the college football
semifinal last year chris uh that was it
for me
i never dreamt in a million years the
jets could be three losses away from
actually having the right to draft him
in the national football league so i
understand
that you point out as you're getting set
to call his game against notre dame and
that there is the heisman trophy that is
in the first week of january there are
more germane questions to ask him
there is none more jermaine to me and
since i have you here
can you ask him how he's doing for me
but you don't know i mean
you told my guys 33 in one college right
and he won everything in high school
right so now you go in there and like
borrow you're going to take more losses
in your first month than you've had in
your career yep and you how do you
handle that when you're uh a fierce
capital f competitor as trevor is and
everything
he doesn't really know what it's like to
lose a game as a starter i mean once
last year in that game in the super
number talking about but but now you've
got to learn to do that you've got to
absorb those you got to stay
positive stay strong and not that he
can't but that's the biggest
adjustment for players coming off great
college teams
into struggling nfl teams all right so
then just tell him i said hello chris
okay that's it that's all i ask then
instead of asking about if i talk to him
again
and uh i'll slip in a jets question just
because i think people the audience is
interested in it i mean
are they trying to lose is that your
professional attention
[Music]
but i'm hoping they do uh chris best to
jennifer have a great cast
uh fowler who you got with jeannette lee
and jay billis this week dan patrick
last week a must listen there
and then next week charles barkley just
in time for the holidays where all
podcasts can be acquired fowler who you
got chris fowler
thanks for having us very kind rich i
appreciate it happy holidays right back
at you
you got it that's chris fowler everybody
chris fowler
here on the rick johnson show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here